Soy desarrollador de juguetes.
Con el sueño de crear nuevos juguetes que nunca se hubieran visto antes,
empecé a trabajar en una empresa de juguetes hace 9 años.
Cuando comencé a trabajar allí,
propuse muchas nuevas ideas a mi jefe todos los días.
Sin embargo, mi jefe siempre pidió
que tuviera datos para demostrar que se venderían
y que pensara en nuevos productos luego de analizar los datos del mercado.
Datos, datos, datos.
Así que analicé los datos de mercado antes de pensar en un producto.
Sin embargo, era incapaz de pensar en algo nuevo en ese momento.
(Risas)
Mis ideas eran poco originales.
No estaba consiguiendo nuevas ideas y me cansé de pensar.
Era tan duro que me volví este flacuchento.
(Risas)
Es cierto. (Aplausos)
Probablemente han tenido experiencias similares y lo sintieron así también.
Su jefe estaba siendo difícil. Los datos eran difíciles.
Se enfermó de pensar.
Ahora, yo tiro los datos.
Mi sueño es crear nuevos juguetes.
Y ahora, en lugar de datos,
estoy usando un juego llamado Shiritori para llegar a nuevas ideas.
Me gustaría introducir este método hoy.
¿Qué es Shiritori?
Tomen manzana, elefante y trompeta, por ejemplo.
El juego es que por turnos se digan palabras
que empiecen con la última letra de la palabra anterior.
Es lo mismo en japonés que en inglés.
Pueden jugar Shiritori como quieran:
"Neko, kora, raibu, burashi", etc., etc. [Gato, cola, concierto, cepillo]
Muchas palabras al azar van a salir.
Ud. fuerza esas palabras para conectarlas a lo que quiere pensar y formar ideas.
En mi caso, por ejemplo, ya que quiero pensar en juguetes,
¿qué podría ser un gato de juguete?
Un gato que cae después de hacer un salto mortal desde un lugar alto?
¿Qué tal un juguete con cola?
¿Una pistola de juguete que dispara soda y deja a alguien empapado?
(Risas)
La ideas ridículas están bien. La clave es mantenerlas fluyendo.
Cuantas más ideas producen, seguro surgen algunas buenas, también.
Un cepillo, por ejemplo. ¿Podemos hacer de un cepillo de dientes un juguete?
Podríamos combinar un cepillo de dientes con una guitarra y...
(Sonidos musicales)
Tienen un juguete que pueden tocar mientras se cepillan los dientes.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
A los niños que no les gusta a cepillarse los dientes; podría empezar a gustarles.
¿Podemos hacer un sombrero en un juguete?
¿Qué tal algo como un juego de ruleta, en el que por turnos se pone el sombrero
y al que se lo pone, un alienígena aterrador sale de la parte superior
gritando, "¡Ahh!"
¿Me pregunto si habría una demanda de esto en las fiestas?
Ideas que no surgieron mirando fijamente los datos, comenzarán a salir.
Este plástico de burbujas, que se utiliza para embalar objetos frágiles,
combinado con un juguete, hizo el Mugen Pop Pop,
un juguete en que se puede hacer estallar burbujas tanto como quiera.
Fue un gran éxito cuando llegó a las tiendas.
Los datos no tenían nada que ver con su éxito.
A pesar de que solo está haciendo estallar las burbujas,
es una gran manera de matar el tiempo,
así que por favor pase por ahí
entre Uds. hoy y jueguen con él.
(Aplausos)
De todas formas, sigues con ideas inútiles.
Piensen en muchas ideas triviales, todos.
Si basan sus ideas en el análisis de datos y saben a lo que están apuntando,
van a terminar intentando demasiado fuerte
y no podrán producir nuevas ideas.
Incluso si saben cuál es su objetivo,
piensen en ideas tan libremente como lanzar dardos con los ojos cerrados.
Si hace esto, seguramente alguno dará en el centro.
Al menos uno lo hará
Ese es el único que debe elegir.
Si lo hacen, esa idea será demandada
y, por otra parte, será la nueva marca.
Eso es lo que pienso de las nuevas ideas.
No tiene que ser Shiritori; hay muchos métodos diferentes.
Solo hay que elegir las palabras al azar.
Pueden hojear un diccionario y elegir palabras al azar.
Por ejemplo, podrían mirar dos letras al azar y recopilar los resultados
o ir a la tienda y conectar los nombres de productos
con lo que quieren pensar.
El punto es reunir palabras al azar,
no la información de la categoría que Ud. están pensando.
Si hacen esto, recogen los ingredientes para la asociación de ideas
y forman conexiones que van a producir muchas ideas.
La mayor ventaja de este método es el flujo continuo de imágenes.
Debido a que están pensando en una palabra tras otra,
la imagen de la palabra anterior todavía está con Uds.
Esa imagen se relacionará automáticamente con palabras futuras.
Sin darse cuenta, un concierto se conectará a un cepillo
y un juego de la ruleta a un sombrero.
Ni se daría cuenta de ello.
Puede llegar a ideas que no habría pensado de lo contrario.
Este método es, por supuesto, no solo para juguetes.
Pueden tener ideas para libros, aplicaciones,
eventos y muchos otros proyectos.
Espero que todos prueben este método.
Hay futuros que nacen a partir de datos.
Sin embargo, el uso de este juego tonto llamado Shiritori,
espero con interés el futuro emocionante que va a crear,
un futuro que ni siquiera podrían imaginar.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)